hi I'm Kim Kardashian West
[Music]
oh yeah North's poking fun at her mom
Kim Kardashian and this time it's from
the beauty mogul's iconic Keeping Up
with the Kardashians moments having kids
is just there's no way to describe it
but it's a lot check out northy's outfit
she rocks a bleach blonde wig to match
her mama's current hairdo and caution
tape to Twin with Kim's famous
Balenciaga outfit yeah Bible it's a
great look the best part about the
nine-year-old's video her lip singing to
a viral mashup of her mom's most
memorable quotes including the notable
earring in the ocean moment
oh and the scene where Kim's ugly cry
meme was born you don't think I feel bad
now this isn't the first time North
trolled Kim you just gotta roll with it
last year Kim's oldest kiddo made fun of
the voice she uses when she posts on
social media okay I'm gonna open it and
show you guys
why do I talk different for what when I
do videos for my videos I'm the same
human being I don't talk different how
do I talk different guys do you think I
talk different when I'm talking about
Contour yeah
and most recently North threw some shade
at her mama on the Kardashians and this
is my daughter Dorothy
hold on baby I'm telling them a story it
all happened at Kim's office for the
skims icons campaign shoe featuring Tyra
Banks Heidi Klum Alessandro Ambrosio and
Candice Swanepoel you have no idea how
iconic this is you just have no idea it
just
they were legendary they are legendary
in a while Kim took some snaps with the
famous models North slid in with the
shade
shorter
but we know it's all love between the
mother-daughter Duo I don't know how
you're gonna top that you don't think I
feel bad I feel sad I hate my sisters
again
[Music]